en este vídeo vamos a aprender cómo
calcular la distancia entre cualquier
par de puntos en nuestro plano
coordinado x 10 y lo que vamos a ver es
realmente una aplicación del teorema de
pitágoras así que vamos a empezar con un
ejemplo digamos que tengo el punto y lo
voy a dibujar déjenme ponerlo así este
es el punto 3 menos 4 así que si lo
gráfica moss me voy hasta el 3 y luego
bajamos 1 2 3 4 muy bien aquí está este
es el 3 menos 4 y ahora digamos que
tengo el punto 6 0 ok el 6,0 así que me
voy hasta el 6 que está aquí y no me
muevo en la dirección de verdad así que
aquí está nuestro punto 6 0 este es el 6
0 y lo que quiero hacer es calcular la
distancia entre estos dos puntos que tan
distante está este azul del naranjita y
en principio como pueden ver tú dirás
oye pero tú me prometiste que vamos a
aplicar el teorema
pitágoras y yo no veo ningún triángulo
aquí bueno si no lo ven déjenme
dibujarlo por ustedes déjenme dibujarlo
ok este triángulo justo de aquí justo
así déjenme utilizar varios colores aquí
ok
así que aquí está nuestro triángulo y
quizás pueda reconocer inmediatamente
que es un triángulo rectángulo correcto
en la base de esto la base de esto es es
perpendicular a la altura así que
estamos tratando con un triángulo
rectángulo ok así podemos utilizar el
teorema de pitágoras para determinar
cuál es la longitud del lado contrario
al ángulo recto que se lo conocemos como
hipotenusa verdad la distancia es la
hipotenusa de este triángulo rectángulo
déjenme escribirlo la distancia
es igual a la hipotenusa de este
triángulo rectángulo verdad así que
déjenme dibujarlo un poquito más grande
de este lado tenemos aquí nuestra
hipotenusa después tenemos los lados de
este triángulo rectángulo que van justo
de forma vertical este y la base ok
vamos a llamar a esta distancia de esa
es la distancia de la hipotenusa y como
encontramos esto a partir de la base y
de la altura bueno vamos a ver primero
cuánto mide la base podríamos verlo en
la gráfica verdad pero bueno aquí aquí
lo que vamos a hacer es que x es 3 en el
primer punto y en el segundo es 6 así
que la distancia simplemente será restar
estos dos números verdad literalmente es
el punto final en x que en este caso es
6 le vamos a restar el punto inicial en
x entonces va a ser 6 menos
23 verdad ok 63 y esa es la distancia de
aquí que es igual a 3
así que ya tenemos la base ahora sólo
para recordar que esto es igual al
cambio en x verdad esto es igual a to x
final menos el x inicial que 6 menos 3
y esto es delta x ahora por tanto
siguiendo la misma línea de razonamiento
esta altura va a ser el cambio y nye
cambio en detalle así que el iev final
en este caso es 0 que es el más alto y
el más bajo es menos 4 así que tendremos
que el cambio en 0 - menos 4 ok me tomo
el más grande y le restó el más pequeño
en este caso es lo mismo que con las x
verdad así que si si tú lo hicieras al
revés bueno vas a obtener un número
negativo pero vamos a quedarnos con este
razonamiento así que del taller es 4
y puedes contar los cuadritos en la
gráfica pero bueno ahora lo importante
es que podemos aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras esta distancia elevado al
cuadrado al cuadrado verdad hay que
tener cuidado porque es la distancia al
cuadrado es igual a delta x al cuadrado
que es la base más delta y al cuadrado
que es la altura y no es nada no es nada
raro verdad a veces le llaman a este la
fórmula de la distancia simplemente es
el teorema de pitágoras que es la base
al cuadrado más la altura al cuadrado
nos da la hipotenusa al cuadrado así que
vamos a aplicar esto con los números que
ya tenemos así que la distancia al
cuadrado va a ser igual a delta x al
cuadrado que es 3 al cuadrado más delta
y al cuadrado que es 4 al cuadrado que
esto es igual a 9 + 16 que es 25 así que
la distancia es la raíz cuadrada perdón
la distancia al cuadrado es 25 y la
distancia es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
25 así que esto nos da la raíz
de 25 que es igual a 5 muy bien así que
esta distancia de aquí es 5 y si miramos
si miramos esto esta distancia es la
solución al problema original verdad son
5 unidades las que distan de las que
distan estos dos puntos así que como
vemos aquí está la fórmula de la
distancia que es simplemente el teorema
de pitágoras si quieren pueden a lo
mejor pensarlo como algunas otras
personas digamos que si tengo dos puntos
digamos x1 y 1 y este es un punto
particular no importa cuál y digamos que
hay otro punto el x 2,2 ok a veces
verás esta fórmula de de la distancia lo
verás a lo mejor en muchas otras formas
pero bueno esto nos dice que la
distancia es igual a la raíz cuadrada
realmente el teorema de pitágoras como
ya vimos que es la distancia
x 2 - x 1
ok - x 1 al cuadrado más que dos
déjenme ponerlo con este color de 2
- menos de uno y todo esto al cuadrado
esto es lo que va a saber en muchos
libros de texto y esta es la famosa
fórmula de la distancia y eso es una
pérdida de tiempo realmente memorizar la
porque realmente es el teorema de
pitágoras esto es delta equis y que
realmente no importa aquí cual elijamos
como x1 y x2 verdad porque cuando
elevamos al cuadrado si es un signo
positivo o negativo da lo mismo y bueno
el otro desde el taller aquí estamos
diciendo que
la raíz cuadrada bueno si elevamos al
cuadrado de ambos lados esto va a ser
delta x al cuadrado la distancia al
cuadrado va a ser delta x al cuadrado
más delta al cuadrado y no quiero
confundir temas del taller significa el
cambio en ye que es la diferencia entre
las leyes de los dos puntos pero bueno
vamos a hacer un ejemplo y tomás digamos
que tengo este punto digamos nos vamos
hasta el -6 y menos cuatro menos seis
coma menos menos cuatro ok y digamos que
queremos hallar la distancia entre éste
y el 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
17 muy bien en este punto está distancia
es la que queremos hallar y es la misma
idea utilizamos el teorema de pitágoras
podemos figurar esta distancia en base a
nuestro cambio en xy nuestro cambio y
esta distancia al cuadrado más esta otra
distancia al cuadrado nos da la
hipotenusa al cuadrado así que vamos a
hacerlo nuestro camión x simplemente
tomamos el digo no importa nos tomamos
el x más grande y le restamos el x más
pequeño así que la distancia al cuadrado
va a ser cuál es nuestro cambio en x
tenemos que el más grande es x igual a 1
y le restamos menos 6 verdad que es el x
más pequeño y esto al cuadrado más el
cambio en el más grande es el más grande
de 7 y le restamos menos 4 y esto lo
elevamos al cuadrado y como elegí estos
números al azar realmente no creo que
salgan números muy muy bonitos pero
bueno vamos a obtener que la distancia
al cuadrado es 1 - menos 6 que sí
y esto al cuadrado ok puedes incluso
contarlo aquí van 4 5 6 7 ese es este
número muy bien ese es nuestro cambio en
x + ahora siete menos menos cuatro que
eso es 11 y esto es al cuadrado que
puedes contar esta distancia aquí en la
gráfica verdad tuvimos 11 cuadritos
tenemos siete menos menos cuatro que es
11 y esto es 11 al cuadrado muy bien así
que vamos a sacar la cual la calculadora
aunque así que la distancia esto esto lo
calculamos así 7 al cuadrado más 11 al
cuadrado
esto es 170 y la distancia es la raíz
cuadrada del resultado anterior verdad
así que cuál es la raíz cuadrada tomamos
la raíz cuadrada de 170 y eso nos da
13.000
13.04 ya redondeando verdad así que esta
distancia de aquí
13.04
ojalá hayas encontrado esto muy útil